i think we can all agree that bill burr
is the funniest guy in the world and the
dopest first affordable e-bike comes
from electricebikes.com
more on that later
were you touring when the um pandemic
happened and then you didn't have to get
on the plane you're like thank god i'll
tell you the one thing i did not miss
was lax for sure yeah i just i every
time i go into lax all it is is you just
want to get to your seat on the plane
and know that your bag
fit yeah and then it's just like okay
now
i have the amazing technology of travel
where i'm gonna go across the country
what used to take people you know months
and they die and [ __ ] i'm gonna do this
for six hours i'm gonna [ __ ] complain
louis ck had a great bit about that
and um
but i never forgot that because i was
one of those people bitching on the
plane i saw louie one time on conan just
going dude you're in the [ __ ] sky oh
the internet doesn't work it's like yeah
yeah what you're like really did you fly
i'm just gonna use they had to like hike
through the [ __ ] mountains that were
just flying over them you're just in
there jesus christ
i was totally one of those guys it was
one of like my favorite bits i that i
love and louie does this a lot in guys
at his caliber where it's they sort of
expose you
for the the [ __ ] you are and it's
it's those jokes are the best one you
buy yourself because you can't play it
off you just got to sit there like yeah
he's right
i'm 100 guilty of complaining
i complained about airports and
airplanes so much like i can't but after
the pandemic when we came back and we
had to wear the [ __ ] masks and and
just like after that break it it was so
much harder to get through an airport
and a flight and they were like delayed
more because there was no people flying
i was a big mass guy dude i loved him
i'm down for him i love the mask i
[ __ ] loved the mask you like wearing
it you like other people wearing it like
i mean i i've given up on on on all of
that or whatever because i don't even
know if they even [ __ ] worked at this
point sure what i mean but um but i was
gonna listen to some [ __ ] who has no
medical degree tell me they don't
[ __ ] work oh is that what your
[ __ ]
degree your lack of a degree tells you
it's just like so i'm gonna go
with the liars i know
rather than people that
you know know that they're being lied to
but then it's like well then now what do
i do now i'm gonna step off into the
wild
and just assume because someone got
kicked out of the medical field that
they were one of the good guys they get
not everybody who gets kicked out of the
medical field gets kicked out because
they're a good person and they're
telling the truth there is that yeah and
there's definitely you know
pharmaceutical companies synthetic
heroin all kinds of crazy [ __ ] that they
don't get called on killing a bunch of
people uh you know so i understood where
like that was coming from but like you
know i was in my emotions like everybody
else and you just wanted it to be over
and it was just like just do what they
say so at least we're all on the same
page so they can get some sort of
analytics to try to get us out of it so
i was into that for a while and then
after a while i was just like
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna sound like
the old man you know pick up your trash
i didn't i was just like all right i'm
gonna do what i you know i think
everybody at some point came to uh i'm
gonna do
what feels right and then like that but
i gotta be honest i miss the mask
i miss it dude
dude you get out of so many [ __ ]
conversations like conversations become
quicker it's like
it just becomes really efficient and
then you just get the [ __ ] out of there
and then there's like there's no record
of you really being there you're always
just walking around like you're robbing
a bank it was kind of [ __ ] awesome i
i i was in an airport yesterday and i
had two thoughts as i walked in oh i
don't have to wear a mask but then i was
my next thought was oh but i'm about to
walk into like the hell of taking
pictures every [ __ ] five seconds and
i was like man i had a panic that i
didn't have my mask in my pocket
yeah i just want to cover my face yeah
it's like a kind of unfortunately don't
really have to deal with that
it's just good now you're this guy's a
[ __ ] movie star man like i i have my
niche i got my [ __ ] jokes and the people
that like it and i'll just run into
somebody like hey aren't you that guy
right he's like yeah i like being at
that level and if you use the promo code
stevo at electric
ebikes.com that's
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-b-i-k-e-s
dot-com
then you get a free foldable and
mountable bike lock with any bike
purchase again you're going up to 45
miles at up to 28 miles per hour this
thing is awesome and affordable i mean
dude get over there to electric
ebikes.com
and join the affordable electric bike
revolution